hallo meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zum minecraft hero projekt
der nachfolger vom mega projekt mehr
oder weniger hier auf meinem kanal
deswegen möchte ich euch ganz kurz mal
vorstellen welche alles dabei sind zwar
so dass diese ganzen leute hier derzeit
von den gehört sicher erst mal runter
drauf das ist ja das ist richtig
da haben wir zum beispiel simon schafft
phd wolf in den cee ronny teilte fmc
experte eric aid im brot pilz jet ski
kilian mister outback debitor und tadel
die sind alle mit dabei und das wird auf
jeden fall hammer geil ich zeige euch
jetzt mal die geilen erste hier von
denen es ist geil was das genau ist das
geil so und dann würde ich sagen wenn du
lieben freund ich freue mich auf jeden
fall mega auf dieses projekt und es wird
hammer geil und ich würde sagen ich
hoffe ihr habt daran genauso spaß wie
ich was denkt ihr was wird euch alles
erwarten schreibt man die kommentare
beim nächsten mal wieder bei der
nächsten folge